was there a point in your life early on
or whenever where you said this is all
I'm gonna be able to do is be an actor
yeah yeah I had that I had that you want
to call it an epiphany I had that way
back I had it when I got out of college
I my father had a bowling buddy who who
was a claims adjuster for Aetna life
insurance and mr. blackwell you know he
got me a job coming out of school for
Aetna and the funny thing is Edna I was
supposed to be outside claims rep which
means that I was opposed to working off
his half the time and go out and take
pictures and go do stuff out in the
field it's ironic that I couldn't handle
the the freedom of being out I didn't
have a discipline at that point to
handle the freedom of being out on the
road for the job I couldn't handle it
and it was really crazy is in what I do
now it's all that you know because I'm
self-employed I mean you know so and
I've been that way for years but I
couldn't I couldn't stay on that job
because I recognized that it wasn't for
me and I was like okay this is really
weird
I can't do this and the day I quit that
job was the day that I was supposed to
be there for a meeting
and I missed a meeting cuz I was just
really at my in my little apartment I
was just like oh man this is just not
I'm not gonna make it I mean I was
floundering like that in my mind at that
point and I was like I'm not gonna make
it so I was late coming into the office
when I got there my boss is like what
don't worry you missed the meeting I
said there's no need for that he says
what do you mean no need for that I said
I quit so I had you know my dictaphone
and my little camera and all my stuff
that you use out in the field I put it
on his desk I said I quit he said you
quit what do you mean you quit I said I
quit so they really like me on the job
because you know my personality
people love me on the job because I hate
everybody laughing all the time and I
told him I said this is not from me so
he said wait a minute wait a minute
he took
me huge - he was my supervisor he took
me to the manager of the floor and in in
corporate America the higher you go up
the the more important and more
prestigious and bigger your job so they
took me floor by floor to all these
different people the superintendent and
they hand me in his office these plush
offices and they sitting at grilling me
you can't leave why are you leaving what
are you doing that we trained you we did
this I said I just I'm sorry I can't do
this and this is that that affirmative
action kind of thing you know what he
said they're gonna think we we ran you
out and said no no no no no no no no no
no no I'll sign any papers you want
saying that you you I say you the
sweetest nicest people they were really
nice people I'm like no no no no no this
is not me they took me all the way up to
the top to the president and he's
sitting behind this big giant desk you
know like in the movies where they had
these big executives he had that kind of
desk and I'm sitting there like this
little young guy 22 years old sitting
like this and he says what's going on
and I said I'm supposed to be in show
business
he says what I said I'm supposed to be
in show business
he said why is that I said well I talked
to a buddy of mine who's not in the
business at all and he said that if
there was one job you could do for the
rest of your life that no matter what
happened or if somebody put a gun up to
your head and said quit that job or I'll
blow your head off
he said you supposed to say shoot
meaning this is it and my buddy told me
says think about it cuz he's real he
still is to this day very philosophical
guy and he said go home and just think
on it pray on it or whatever you want to
do and I did and he said call me
tomorrow and I called him the next day I
said I want to be an actor and a singer
and all that I want to be an
entertainment business so he said well
then you need to let your job know I
went in and quit the job my parents
naturally freaked out they were like
what but that was that was what I had to
do
and I was engaged at the time and I lost
my fiancee because she had my life all
mapped out for me I was supposed to do
that job because being a claims adjuster
for from in corporate America you
basically are a law clerk technically
because you compile all the information
for a different claim or whatever and I
was handling some real big claims and
you take that and you give it to the
corporate attorney who goes into court
to try to fight the other side because
either they don't want to pay a lot of
money or they don't want to pay any
money at all so they go into court on it
so that was basically what the job was
so she said you're gonna do this job
you're either gonna get your masters in
business or you gonna get you gonna go
to law school and she had it all mapped
out I said I can't do this this is just
I mean I was having problems with my
stomach I mean you know I was like
losing sleep and everything I was like
just I said I can't do this I quit that
whole thing she dumped me and it seemed
like overnight things started happening
and I went to uh and this is a really
crazy but I went out to dinner with a
couple of friends and they were
consoling me about it and I'm like I
might have made the wrong mistake I
might have done something I might I
should have done what she said they said
no and this is this is crazy but I
started looking at the silverware on the
table as they were talking to me
consoling me and I was just looking at
the silverware and all of a sudden I
came up I said within the next couple of
years I'm gonna be doing commercials and
I'm gonna be doing stuff and I'm gonna
be in music I'm gonna be singing in the
acting on stage I mean they said really
that's it yeah
within the next couple of years I was
doing that I got in a show in Detroit
call this is your Detroit it was a 30
minute show you remember the I don't
know you might be too young to remember
the Mitch Miller and all that you know
all that kind of stuff
the singers in holiday like Lawrence
Welk it all together I mean this is way
before all that time but it was one of
those kind of things and we did a
30-minute show about the good things
about Detroit which should have lasted
about two minutes but we stretched it up
to 30 min
and I sang and did all this and I
actually had studied see how my
politically trained I started I met a
guy but all by accident friend of Mines
mother owns an antique shop and I wanted
to take voice lessons so this man came
in mr. Harris came in to buy an antique
chair or something and she said I've
seen you in here before the lady that
always says what do you do he says well
I'm a music teacher you know at one of
the high schools and he said I teach you
know voice and this and that so uh my
son's best friend you know he's like my
son he wants to take music lessons voice
lessons well giving my number I studied
with this man Society years and I
learned operatic technique and
everything and then he sent me to his
teacher who was like an Italian man who
had actually trained and worked with
Pavarotti and all those people you know
in Italy so I became afraid to be
trained I never really used it because
foreign languages is always one of my
weaknesses so I was like wow so I
actually had an audition my teacher said
okay I want you to go audition for the
mint they're coming in town I said the
Metropolitan Opera he says you won't get
it because you don't know the language
but I want them to hear you so here I am
you know big afro wearing a tank top and
some and some jeans and you know I'll be
buffed at the time because I'm just
coming out of playing sports so I go to
this audition the only one like me there
you know what I'm saying looking just
like this I walk in there so all of
these people you know these divas and
all these guys and I mean I four people
really like that you know like a
stereotype they all in their me me me me
me me me me doing that so I walk here so
the first question they ask you they say
to me is uh excuse me but you might be
in the wrong place I said well is this
where they holding the auditions for the
Metropolitan they said yes so I said
well this is what I'm here for so the
people stopped it's like yeah but maybe
everybody a I'm old enough to remember
that right
so so what happened was they said oh so
the person came out to say okay who's
next all of the people I said let him go
cuz they wanted to have a good laugh so
they let him go I said oh you sure you
all been neatly said no no no you go so
the people looked at me the lady looked
at me I go into the into the into the
auditorium where they had a piano on
stage and everybody is looking at me you
know a big panel of people from the men
and the Detroit Opera and the
Metropolitan Opera all these people from
the symphony and everything is sitting
in there and they all looking at me like
so what are you gonna sing you had to do
a dramatic piece and you had to do a
light comedic piece I said I'm going to
sing for my dramatic piece at least is
why tomorrow from Tusker and I'm going
to do una forty-four lagrima from Elia I
do more and they like really they said
well you're gonna which one do first I
said oh well I want to do the the
lighter piece first to warm up and I
started singing know your kiss for
wounds and or any people looking at me
like this I'm saying that then they were
like looking around like this then I
sang my dramatic few look a lot of still
air and I hit the high C which is the
tenor I'm a tenor I'm a dramatic tenor
which means I have a the big tenor voice
okay there's a light lyric tenor and I'm
the heavier tenor that's almost like a
baritone which is the rare voice so they
hear me hit this high seat and the man
from the Met jumps up and he runs up to
the edge of the stage and all these
stuff speaking Italian and I look at him
I say huh
oh you don't speaker to tell you the
narwhals being none of that so that was
the end of my Metropolitan Opera
experience in my operatic aspirations
because I couldn't get the language so I
used it for musical theater and I was
singing in all the musicals around
Detroit and I mean I was singing you
know Oklahoma
you know because the voice was strong
enough to do if you can do our you can
do anything else it's like it's like
ballet and dance you know ballet if you
notice people that study ballet when
they do jazz or whatever you could see
the difference their stuff is just their
line and all of that is just so much
more pronounced so I did musical theater
I got an agent who came to see me in the
musical and that's when I got my
commercial thing going what happened
when you walked past all the people that
were there that when you know what I
left
hmm they were all like looking at me
like and one guy came up says you have
the most incredible voice but see my
teachers trained me I mean I did I
trained for eight years and and and the
thing is my car broke down
and I would like kiss the bus and in
Detroit catching the bus is like being
you know you remember Mad Max you know
you know I did I did in the wilderness
you know where you just out there I mean
getting a bus ride in Detroit is crazy
so I would be a in the cold going to my
music lessons and I had it I ended up
taking a little job I took a job as a
working at a halfway house for some
little kids you know just to sustain
myself when I substitute talk just to
keep the money flowing while I trained
and you know my parents and everybody
was like uh he's just flipped out all
the way you know because they didn't
they didn't think I was serious or I had
really they didn't didn't believe what I
believe and I felt it I mean I knew what
I was supposed to be doing so when I got
my first agent my first agent as a
commercial actor and doing TV and film
stuff when I went in the interview I had
a friend of mine sister take my first
headshots and I mean she was in she was
in photography school so she had those
you know those pictures my dad you know
the war like you know the prison
pictures yeah
[ __ ] cuz she didn't know any better than
I had those and I had to it was a GQ
thing thank you like a GQ look you know
and when I took the pictures to that
agent who saw me in the in the musical
because she came on gave me a card and I
was the only one she gave a car to and
all of course other actors and
everything like they were mad oh yeah so
I went to see her and she says do you
have any pictures were you smiling
I said no she's a smile I said Wow you
got a beautiful smile I want you to go
see this photographer I said well she's
I know you don't have much money but go
see this photographer tell him I sent
you he's going to shoot you this guy
shot me some new headshots well I'm like
this the whole thing and she had me come
back so she she handed me a script she
said okay read this it was a Kentucky
Fried Chicken commercial script so I had
never done anything like this so I read
the script she says you're gonna be good
you're gonna be good in the commercials
one day you're gonna be good
but you'll never do voiceover I'm like
oh what's the voiceover she told me I
said oh so she signed me and everything
and sent me out on stuff but it kind of
upset me the fact that she said I would
never do voiceover because it's like you
know I never do voiceover you know so at
that point it became a burnin up session
to learn voiceover so as fate or God or
whatever who would have it I moved into
an apartment where this guy down the
hall from me named Dennis was an
engineer at a recording studio and we've
met in the laundry room and he said hey
you new in the building I said oh yeah
he said so what'd you do I said well try
to be an actor or whatever and he said
oh he said what else you do I said well
that's basically it I got a little
regular job I said but I really want to
try to do this voice-over stuff he says
really he says when you finish your
laundry knock on my apartment down I'm
down the hall from me because I know
where you had I'm knocked on it
open this door he's got a full recording
studio I said what is it he says I work
at a studio where we do voiceovers he
taught me how to do voiceovers right so
when I left Detroit I moved to Chicago
I became one of the top african-american
voiceover artists in Chicago I did
everything from McDonald's to amico
which was gasoline I don't know if they
still around they don't call it amico
now I did every product that you had
pepto-bismol I did everything and before
I moved out of Chicago I was going back
and forth from Chicago to San Francisco
I became the voice of Bank of America oh
wow general market and I became the
voices is banking on America
Bank of America so all those 15 years
was 15 years at that point 15 years
later I became one of the top voice of
the guys in Chicago and it got to a
point where I knew it was time for me to
leave by this time my parents were like
believing me like hey you're doing well
I was making a real nice living and I
said well it's time for me to move to LA
and they were like why are you doing so
well you you working you know cuz that
was a complete effort you know the [ __ ]
up and everything else so you you've
been doing this all these years now I'm
like no it's time to go I came out to LA
and I would come back and forth and the
first thing I did I had an audition for
a TV show I booked it and it was for
life goes on no show remember about the
boy yeah yeah I booked it I booked that
and when I was I was in the make up room
in the trailer Patti LuPone and all the
stars when they're being made up they
were real nice welcome to the show and
she said so how long have you been out
in LA I just got here two weeks ago and
this is my first audition everybody said
what I did a recurring on the show did a
couple episodes on the show and whatnot
and then I started doing other stuff and
then it became a tug of war between here
and Chicago so eventually I went back to
Chicago cuz I was involved with another
woman who didn't want to leave because
she was running her own insurance
company so I'm like I said well we need
to move to LA she says no I'm making
much more than you so that that whole
situation
that engagement went out the window so I
said you know I'm just a complete loser
when it comes to you know getting
married so I said well maybe it's time
to focus on the career so I came here
and I started working and working and
then we went on strike and all my
commercial stuff happened to be running
out at the same time we went on strike
I had partied all my money away here
hanging out and doing all kind of crazy
stuff in LA so I said okay I gotta find
a little job so I took a little
part-time little hustle job which turned
out to be like a seven-year job almost
for Nielson and I was handing out movie
passes and stuff so that was a nice way
you know to get out to meet people was
flexible enough from auditions and I met
a lot of women and I've met a lot of
women because it's easy see when a guy
has a has something he's selling it's
easy you disarm women you know but when
you walk up like hey excuse me you know
that wall comes up he's like hey would
you like to see movie so I met a lot of
women like that and it's segue into
relationships you know that works it
works you know so that's what basically
happened on that and then after a few
years of that I started really clicking
in the business again here and I didn't
have time to do it and then at that
point you know I wouldn't even show up
for there they eventually had to fire me
from that job and and all the people on
the job and all those people you know
who I work for they well said it like
that's cool I'm gonna do this stuff and
so I've been doing I've been doing
commercial and TV and films to have ever
since as far as that um I've done over
200 commercials 200 on-camera
commercials you know over the years and
then I've done quite a few voiceovers in
fact I have I'm on the rocky and
bullwinkle or the new rocky and
bullwinkle cartoons I play this
character called a fetus Texas
billionaire little squirrel I like that
squirrel you got hanging out with it
that moves with the three corner head
Bullwinkle yeah I like him sabe que ting
that character and then also did a I'm
also on Barbie's Dreamhouse I play a
couple of characters on there and then I
I'm on this little show called a wild
grinders it's kind of like The Little
Rascals on skateboards and I play the
little dog on the show and he's on a
skateboard
so I mean I do that I don't I haven't
done those recently but I got those
still running and whatnot but it's been
a good experience you know
you